if you've watched the news or followed
politics chances are you've heard the
term Orwellian thrown around in one
context or another but have you ever
stopped to think about what it really
means or why it's used so often the term
was named after British author Eric
Blair known by his pen name George
Orwell because his most famous work the
novel 1984 depicts an oppressive society
under a totalitarian government
Orwellian is often used simply to mean
authoritarian but using the term in this
way not only fails to fully convey
Orwell's message it actually risks doing
precisely what he tried to warn against
Orwell was indeed opposed to all forms
of tyranny spending much of his life
fighting against anti-democratic forces
of both the left wing and the right but
he was also deeply concerned with how
such ideologies proliferate and one of
his most profound insights was the
importance that language plays in
shaping our thoughts and opinions
of 1984's Oceania controls its people's
actions and speech in some ways that are
obvious
their every move and word is watched and
heard and the threat of what happens to
those who step out of line is always
looming overhead
other forms of control are not so
obvious
the population is inundated with a
constant barrage of propaganda made up
of historical facts and statistics
manufactured in the Ministry of Truth
the Ministry of peace is the military
labor camps are called joy camps
political prisoners are detained and
tortured in the ministry of love this
deliberate irony is an example of
doublespeak
when words are used not to convey
meaning but to undermine it corrupting
the very ideas they refer to
the regime's control of language goes
even further eliminating words from the
English language to create the official
dialect of Newspeak a crudely limited
collection of acronyms and simple
concrete nouns lacking any words complex
enough to encourage nuanced or critical
thought this has an effect on the psyche
Orwell calls doublethink a hypnotic
state of cognitive dissonance in which
one is compelled to disregard their own
perception in place of the officially
dictated version of events
leaving the individual completely
dependent on the state's definition of
reality itself the result is a world in
which even the privacy of one's own
thought process is violated where one
may be found guilty of thought crime by
talking in their sleep
and keeping a diary or having a love
affair equals a subversive act of
rebellion
unlike something that can only happen in
totalitarian regimes
but Orwell was warning us about the
potential for this occurring even in
democratic societies and this is why
authoritarian alone does not or well in
make
in his essay politics and the English
language he described techniques like
using pretentious words to project
Authority we're making atrocities sound
acceptable by burying them in euphemisms
and convoluted sentence structures but
even more mundane abuses of language can
affect the way we think about things the
words you see in here in everyday
advertising have been crafted to appeal
to you and affect your behavior as have
the sound bites and talking points of
political campaigns which rarely present
the most nuanced perspective on the
issues and the way that we use
ready-made phrases and responses gleaned
from media reports or copied from the
internet makes it easy to get away with
not thinking too deeply or questioning
your assumptions
so the next time you hear someone use
the word Orwellian pay close attention
if they're talking about the deceptive
and manipulative use of language they're
on the right track if they're talking
about mass surveillance and intrusive
government they're describing something
authoritarian but not necessarily
Orwellian and if they use it as an
all-purpose word for any ideas they
dislike it's possible their statements
are more Orwellian than whatever it is
they're criticizing
words have the power to shape thought
language is the currency of politics
forming the basis of society from the
most common everyday interactions to the
highest ideals Orwell urged us to
protect our language because ultimately
our ability to think and communicate
clearly is what stands between us and a
world where war is peace and freedom is
slavery